good morning
sorry i'm a couple of minutes late
i uh
a little bit of a late breakfast brought
my tea in here
so
one of the most common
uh comments that i get when i talk to
people about how i like learning
languages
uh if they're even interested which
actually is often the case people in
fact very often say yeah i wish i spoke
spanish especially here in the states
um i'd like to learn languages you're
lucky you have a special talent for
language learning
and if any of you out there
are
you know
bilingual trilingual
multilingual i'm sure you had that same
comment gee i don't have a special
talent
for
uh you know language learning yantian si
as they say in chinese you know
so this seems to be that there's this
perception and it works two ways
not only
is demeaning to the efforts of people
who work hard to learn languages
well it's just a talent
but it also enables these people to it's
a good excuse for not
putting in the effort
or
if they do start to put in the effort
they're kind of convinced that they
don't have that special talent and
therefore they won't succeed
and and i think a lot of that sense that
i can't do it comes from the experience
at school
so
today on twitter
there was an article
and i might even uh
uh
put a
link to it somewhere if i can find it in
my twitter feed
but it showed the
the countries in europe
where they have the largest number of
speakers of other languages
i think how many countries do people
speak
you know how many languages do people
speak so 54321
that was one table and the other table
was
how many in how many countries do people
speak at least one other language so
it's slightly different
and inevitably you know at the top
was liechtenstein or finland
and holland and at the bottom were
france spain and england
and
you know if you analyze this thing and
probably ireland as well
because if you analyze this thing it
comes out what comes out of it is that
the more people speak your language
the less likely you are to learn another
language
and i think that can extend to the
japanese the chinese the russians the
portuguese speakers in brazil
wherever you are in an
environment where a lot of people speak
your language you are less likely to
learn another language
now
what has that got to do with talent well
i doubt
if people in life sweden finland
uh or for that matter singapore or
south africa apparently is very
multilingual i doubt if
if those people have a special talent
for language learning that they have
some genetic predisposition
that developed because they lived in the
forests of scandinavia and they had to
speak 10 different languages it's just
not so
the talent for language learning is
evenly distributed across all
ethnic
divisions
now if we look back on as children we
all learn our first language
we all eventually learn to walk unless
we have some disability
similarly with speaking some people have
don't hear or whatever there could be
some disability but if there is no other
disability we all learn to speak our
first language we don't learn to speak
that first language because we are
instructed in that first language
we don't learn to speak that language
because we have a talent for learning
the language we learn to speak that
first language because we are exposed to
so much of the language
typically listening
listening as children we hear the
language around us
and is that is that exposure to lots of
that language that enables us to
eventually speak the language
now i don't
accept noam chomsky
his theory that we have some innate
universal grammar and whenever i say
that there's always some college
educated linguist that comes up with
some theory about how i don't understand
it but chomsky basically says
because we don't get enough input
what he calls the paucity p-a-u-c-i-t-y
there's a word for non-english speakers
the lack of comes from latin
uh
lack of sufficient content therefore we
can't possibly simply acquire the
language through ex
i don't believe that at all
because
all of the patterns in whatever language
we learned
could it could be swahili it could be
tagalog it could be
you know quechua
the patterns in that language
the brain will eventually sort them out
just as the brain sorts out all kinds of
patterns throughout our lives that's
what the brain is there for is to find
patterns in the things that
we experience so that we aren't always
experiencing them for the first time we
develop an ability to cope that's what
the brain does and it does the same with
language so with enough
exposure as children
we don't need our parents to correct us
minimal impact
otherwise
children of immigrants would all speak
broken english because that's all their
parents can give them but they don't
they end up speaking the same as
all of their peers it's more the
language environment that we live in
and therefore
children in countries where the
television is in the original language
therefore they start getting exposure to
the language
listening at an early age they then are
more likely
to learn another language because i'm
sure that the methods of instruction
language instruction in finland germany
switzerland portugal spain is all more
or less the same
i'll follow the same theories of
language instruction
however
it's the amount of exposure the
listening exposure that determines
whether we're going to learn a language
or not now of course the reading helps a
lot stephen crashing
great proponent of extensive reading i
find that reading is a great place to to
work on increasing your vocabulary
i like reading
i need to see the word written in order
to remember it
uh however i then need to
or to
i i need to see it written or to get a
sense of what was said very often
because just the sound is not clear
enough for me if it's a new word
but once i've seen it and then i need to
hear it many many many times so i've
shown you before
my playlist that link where some items
i've listened to 30 40 times
it's that exposure repeated exposure
certainly the child is exposed to a very
limited range of content but over and
over and over again and that's
essentially what we need to do and
i could show you again my listening
statistics that doesn't mean i don't
struggle in the language i'm struggling
in arabic i have always struggled in
korean i'm gonna go back to korean and
improve every time i go back i improve a
little bit it's not like
instant you know there's no three weeks
three months to fluency it's a lot of
exposure obviously
if you're a spanish speaker learning
portuguese or vice versa
you have so much of the vocabulary
already
you can move quite quickly but otherwise
for the brain to sort through what's
that you know that experience takes a
lot of exposure
um the other thing too is that if the
child
can read they'll learn more quickly but
the average two or three-year-old
doesn't read adults can read therefore
you know it's an added advantage that
the adult learner has again it's not a
matter of talent but the adult learner
has a wide range of vocabulary in his or
her own language
so there's no point in learning a new
word in a new language if you don't even
have that word in your own language
because you don't know what they're
talking about you have to refer
everything back to your base to
something you know
so uh obviously as adults we have a
large vocabulary we have our life
experience we can read so we use all of
those things to learn faster and i think
that adults can learn
languages faster than children
because of those advantages
they may not achieve the same effortless
native pronunciation that children can
achieve because the adults have already
got
you know some other language system
fixed in their brain and they have to
kind of fight that to create some space
for the new language whereas the kids
just it just flows into them they're not
inhibited they're not afraid
they're not afraid to appear childish
whereas adults
are reluctant to feel childish and
therefore there's there are more
inhibitions but leaving that aside
adults can learn more quickly as long as
they give themselves enough exposure so
just uh maybe i'll stop it there if
anybody wants to see my listening
statistics going back
10 years in all the different languages
the way we track them i think you'll see
that i have invested
thousands of hours in listening to
languages and that is the talent the
talent is
the curiosity the willingness
to spend the time with you know
listening to or reading in other
languages
and that's why people in finland sweden
holland and so forth smaller countries
typically are more motivated more
willing to listen to and read and commit
themselves to being exposed to other
languages they have the need they have
more of a need
and that is the talent that doesn't mean
that someone who speaks english cannot
become
a polyglot one has only to look at
richard simcott uh who is british
and who speaks
40 odd languages extremely well okay so
i wanted to make that comment because it
comes up all the time i find it
extremely annoying because it almost
denies the effort that i put in
and it's a bit of an excuse for people
that's not to say however that
you know some people may pronounce
better some people may
you know use the language better
there's a whole range of differences in
outcomes but fundamentally everyone can
learn one or more
additional language
and it's simply a matter of exposing
themselves
to the language
well i say that i do believe i had a
disagreement with someone over grammar i
find as adults it's useful occasionally
to refer to grammar without ever
expecting to remember any of the rules
or any of the tables but simply as an
exposure to the language again so the
occasional reference to grammar
certainly doesn't hurt
but it's not the main state the mainstay
is just as with children
massive exposure to the language and
that doesn't require any special talent
so that's what i wanted to get off my
chest today
for you non-native speakers there's
another idiom you can use
and now i'll see what sorts of questions
we've got here
okay
now let's see where's my little
handy dandy i didn't bring my stylus i
like using a stylus no stylus use my
finger
okay blah blah blah blah
where's our fairest leader i'm not
fearless
uh-huh
yeah
i'm currently learning italian starting
duolingo memorizing link uh struggling
inputs i don't understand what they're
saying should i continue to build a
vocabulary this is from maoist mo is
none
i mean i
started greek
on duolingo and i gave it up
because there's a bunch of
sometimes meaningful sometimes not so
meaningful disconnected sentences it
didn't do it for me
i haven't used memorize
i mean
link in the early days uh you know in
the early stages of learning a language
um where i lost it now it pops around
here
where did that disappear
and let me just stick
it's gone how can that be
anyway the answer is
that in the early stages of the language
i listen more often to the same content
and i um
do more review of words and phrases
using our various what we call
activities so it could be a flashcard
could be multiple choice
could be uh you know uh closed test
dictation so i spent more time
oh message retracted i'm always not
retracted and that's what happened
anyway the answer is in the early stages
yes i do more vocabulary review but
tied to the lesson that i'm studying in
link in other words i don't
personally i have not gone sort of the
memorized anki root where it's just
deliberate study of vocabulary
there are plenty of bilingual religion
regions in spain too yes absolutely
absolutely and those people are totally
bilingual
it's true the best foreign speakers of
english are definitely the dutch and
they watch our tv next well the best the
swedes are pretty good too
or the danes or the norwegians
i just don't understand i got a culture
shock i should say it because of how
different it is
yeah it's different mustafa but
it's also for that reason very
attractive
because it's it's you're opening a door
to a completely new world i found it
fascinating but it's different
my cousin of it is redundant to
constantly look up the definitions of
new words because he has been told that
he should learn new words by heart
is it true or not you can't learn words
by heart the words
first of all the first definition you
look up may or may not explain the use
of that word in your context
uh there typically is a range of meaning
of a word you won't know the word until
you've seen it in many different
contexts to get a real sense of how it's
used and you will learn a word and you
will forget it no matter how well you
think you've learned it you'll forget it
again in many cases so i personally
i
try to expose myself to as much content
as possible and i do
uh
i do uh occasionally especially in the
early stages use the sort of vocabulary
review functions that we have
so brandon english videos
thank you long time no see
song when watching tv television
strictly for listening comprehension
which is better subtitles or no
subtitles i mean this depends on your
level
uh if you are watching the movie
telenovela for fun to stimulate your
interest and as a sort of encouragement
and reward you can have english
subtitles
when you get better it's better to have
spanish sometimes
i personally don't spend a lot of time
uh
with movies other than for enjoyment and
stimulus and encouragement i prefer to
listen and read but it's all a matter of
what people
enjoy doing
yeah john kr you should have seen the
sentences duolingo threw at me for greek
so i got out of there fast
is you're thinking
is your thinking or memory declining
much with ah
i i don't have that impression it's
possible but i feel that i've learned
the languages over the last 10 years
that is after this like i'm 73 now
uh i'm learning languages faster than
ever i've started speaking in persian
after essentially three four months of
study
i spent much longer with my uh check and
even longer with my russian and um
so on down the line i don't feel it's
it's you gotta keep the brain active
uh
how many words do you need in order to
start reading compelling content if you
mean reading compelling content away
from the computer i think it depends
again on the language
but lots the number is lots uh if you're
in inflected languages
you know it could be 30 or 40 000 words
in english it might be a 15 or 20 000.
i think you should use earphones much
more than a loudspeaker for language
learning what do you think charles paul
yeah i i find that i'm better able to
concentrate
when i've got my ear paws or something
in my ear besides which i do a lot of
moving around if i'm cleaning the house
or if i'm exercising or i'm in the car
in the car i'll put on the car i don't
want to drive in my car with my
earphones on
um
here we go gus i understand i link many
stories in greek and have been listening
many times then i turn on the greek news
and i hardly understand anything it's a
little discouraging okay guys the many
stories give you the basic structures of
the language the most common verbs you
get a sense of the sounds of the
language you can actually start speaking
but whether it be greek or any other
language to get from there to the news
is quite a distance and i'm experiencing
that now
in my arabic and that's where the lack
of intermediate content is a problem
uh i did
uh have some greek
i found a greek podcast about the
building of the parthenon which i had
transcribed got paid habits transcribed
i'm not sure i imported them into link
or not
if you can find good audio content you
can go to
a
automatic transcription
website you google automatic
transcription vocalmatic is one of them
take the news throw it on to vocalmatic
and you'll get the text alternately you
can read newspapers in greek which will
have a lot of the same vocabulary but i
find it's best
to to get you know matching matching uh
text to your audio
uh
if we could have more if we could have
we should really extend the mini stories
concept with a lot of repetition but
expand the vocabulary into political and
economic terms
uh
you just have to fight your way through
it that's what it is i would do more
reading of newspapers
uh
okay how useful do you think passive
listening is
for example i listen to roy radio every
day as i have a lot of dead time driving
this is correct
it's not bad it's good it's giving you a
sense of the rhythm the intonation of
the language
when i do that i become curious because
there's simply so many words i don't
understand that's why uh either i go to
something that has a transcript which
might be an ebook
and
naratore by the way craig
naratore.com
is an excellent resource and they offer
audio ebooks matching
audiobooks and ebooks so you can then
import the ebook into link
other than that you have to use
uh these transcription services but i am
always motivated when i'm listening to
things that i don't understand i want to
find some way
that i can get to read it so i can
understand
have i
have you ever used the roman room method
or any
memorizing technique no i i simply have
never been willing
uh
to invest the time
uh into these systems for memorizing i
just allow the exposure to eventually do
the trick
oh i recently started learning finnish
any tips for a gluten of languages sorry
uh i have i mean i think uh japanese and
korean would qualify as agglutinative
languages
turkish when i go to turkish is as well
to me it's not really an issue it's just
every language has its own way of saying
things that you have to simply get used
to and you get used to it through a lot
of exposure i would get on link for sure
we'd have some finished content there
and i would look for other
resources the advantage with finnish
compared to me with arabic and persian
is that it is written in the latin
alphabet that make things makes things a
lot easier
some people recommend to watch the same
movie over and over again what do you
think
well
you know i couldn't do that
um
you know
the um
again i quote very often i quote the
german neuroscientist who said the brain
requires repetition but it also requires
novelty and every time you're going back
to something you've done before it's no
longer novel
and so the brain is less attentive to
that
uh i would not do that but on the other
hand i mean it certainly would help help
you
you know get a better handle on on that
content as long as you're still curious
maybe you missed a bunch of dialogue the
first time and you want to go back in
and try and see if you can't get that
dialogue so somehow the brain is keen
i guess it's not such a bad thing to do
it depends on what you're motivated to i
personally could not do that once i've
seen the movie i've seen it although i
shouldn't say that i wouldn't watch the
same movie again and again but when i
started into russian and i got these
videos from the store ruskimir in
vancouver and there were some lovely
movies i watched maybe two or three
times
uh
but uh no more than that and it was like
you know three months later to see if i
could pick up a little bit more of the
dialogue
how to stop the anxiety when kind of a
person you are able to practice with
well
you know anxiety
to me
if
the big thing is comprehension if i can
understand what the person is saying i
don't mind stumbling
uh and if if it's someone who is
prepared to be patient with me
i don't worry at all if i'm in a
situation you know
even um
you know when i was in saint petersburg
and i go to the train station and i and
russian comprehension is pretty good
but i don't know what the person the
woman behind the counter i want to buy a
train ticket i don't know what she's
going to say someone i said i want a
drink i was going to v-board so i don't
want a ticket to the board and she goes
and i don't know what she asked me
uh and then i asked her to repeat and
then i understood what she was asking if
i had already been in that situation
before
then i would have anticipated what she
was going to say then i would have been
better prepared so to some extent if you
don't know what's going to come at you
it's it it helps to have been in that
situation before but at any rate the big
issue is comprehension if i struggle to
speak it doesn't bother me it's just an
attitude very often we create our own
problems
um
if i can understand i'm happy i don't
have any anxiety
how important is physical activity for
your language learning
let's say that the language learning
makes it more likely that i will work
out every day
uh
because working out is kind of boring
and um
i couldn't also just stand there and
listen
to the language but if i combine working
out
and the uh listening to the language i'm
happy to do it i feel i'm not wasting my
time
so the language learning
is important to my physical activity
more than the reverse
romance says hi all
right
could you give
advice
what we should do when we have boring
but we must learn for work okay
i mean
obviously the best situation is that
you're interested interested in the
language interested in the subject
matter
uh
i would uh i would try and find things
interesting in the language the more you
are not deliberately learning the
language but learning about something
through the language
the better you're gonna learn
do you have a favorite spanish regional
accent
no i mean i think they're all fun i like
being in spain
uh
i like you know the argentinian accent
um
i find that
places like mexico and peru that's
fairly
fairly um
standard i like them all
could you give it
how to stay motivated when people think
learning other languages is useless it
doesn't bother me in the slightest
uh you think you can reach 18 chinese in
three months studying every day yes what
part of language learning do you find
most frustrating
most frustrating is the sense that we're
not progressing as quickly as we would
like that's the most frustrating thing
right now
i mean because it is does take time and
so we're reading and listening and
reviewing words and we have that sense
that we're not making any progress when
in fact we are
and that's part of why we have our
statistics linked to remind you that you
actually have progressed you've acquired
a lot of languages my pages that link
are now more wide i understand more
things but the biggest frustration is
the sense that you're just not making
any progress when in fact you are
giovanni last question do you think the
movie technique is a great way to learn
with movies if you watch our favorite tv
show seen by scene learn okay i mean it
depends what you're interested in i've
said before i to me if i'm going to
watch a tv program i have to sit in
front of the computer or the television
whereas listening i can do it while
working out and reading is relaxing so i
prefer to read and listen but people who
like to watch movies that's fine uh it's
stimulating to watch a movie my wife was
watching a turkish
soap opera like series
there and it was fun i couldn't
understand anything but it kind of says
gee i'm going to learn turkish and if i
had been studying turkish i probably
would have sat there with her to watch
it at least for a while but the kind of
silly stories so you lose interest
how fast you get used to using nouns
with gender correctly in languages as
french spanish remaining it takes a long
time
gender is a bit like tones in chinese it
gradually over a time improves
i don't think it ever gets perfect but
if you get your accuracy up over 50 60
70 80 certain of the gender you know
with the agreement and the adjective and
stuff is going to flow out naturally and
others you'll make mistakes at
i mean how many english how many
non-native speakers of english do you
hear say he go in other words the third
person singular
lots they've been at it for 10 years
they still can't get the fact especially
if the
subject is buried in the sense
the card that i took to the store the
other day
uh
run
slow
instead of runs because they lose track
of
the fact that this is a third person and
therefore they make mistakes these are
minor mistakes the not a big deal
how fast are you
robert has any university begun using
link in their curriculum not that i'm
aware of we would love to work with
universities
or any
universities uh schools
uh
corporate language learners
we'd like to work with them
and and advise them but it's a whole
attitude the attitude that i try to get
across in these sessions that has to
then be part of a university or school
or a corporate learning environment
that uh that wants to use link and and
we can make an attractive deal don't
forget to by the way that we have a
referral program at lincoln if you go to
your profile
you'll see the referral program and if
you can persuade other people in your
class in your course at university uh
it's your place at work to use link then
you get 20
uh what's with the delay from learning
something to improving
further down the line without having
done anything is really spooky sometimes
so if i understand the question
correctly
it means that uh
you'll you'll work on a language
and then you'll put it away aside and
you go back to it three months and
you're better
and i have called this the gestation
period i've called this the benign
neglect period but there's no question i
have experienced this many times
that when i go back to a language that i
study before i'm better i might slip a
little in terms of my vocabulary but
very quickly i'm where i was and i'm
better in the language i don't know how
the brain works but that is certainly
something that i have experienced
ah
it's easy for me to write english i
think words come out of my mind so when
i speak i feel so hard to forget words
yeah that's it of course when we write
we're under no pressure unless we're
writing an exam or something
and we can look things up and so forth
when we're speaking there's more stress
and that's why if you're speaking with
someone who makes you feel comfortable
you do better
typically
if you're speaking with someone who
makes you
feel uneasy you won't do as well so yeah
there's more stress you got to think
find the words on the fly you can't look
things up
it's a little more difficult but you
just have to keep going keep doing it
more listening more reading and speaking
whenever you have the opportunity
i've been learning german for a year but
i still don't feel comfortable with the
language what should i do there's always
tons of words to learn
luis enrique welcome to the world of
language learning it takes time you just
have to
trust the process
you know remember why you're learning
the language you want to learn the
language and you just stay with and
eventually you slowly slowly get better
uh language
is majoring in a language like chinese
are good or bad idea
what am i supposed to answer
majoring in anything is a good idea if
that's what you're interested in
steve did you ever find reading japanese
is easier than listening
no not really in fact i didn't
i find reading japanese tough because
they use hiragana katakana and kanji i
prefer to read chinese in straight kanji
but listening i didn't find no because i
did so much listening i never found
listening to japanese is difficult and
part of that is i don't mind when i
don't understand but i just keep
listening and listening and listening
and eventually i understand more
mustafa yeah imitating actors uh
pronunciation is an excellent idea the
more we imitate the better
here
thank you craig fred
craig by the way if you were the one i
don't know whether you are italian or
you're learning italian but raidu has
some excellent excellent content
and uh again without transcript but we
also have a lot of good stuff in link
with transcript i did the promesces
posie and pinocchio which was great
being able to browse a list of our known
words and link would be great and i
guess it'd be quite easy to implement
the system in some way has to have this
list somewhere it'd be the only way to
work
uh it would be
yeah i mean it has come up before i
don't know whether we in fact do keep a
list of your known words
i don't know how i would never do it
uh i see my numbers all the time time in
my text as i'm reading
we have to also be a little careful i
mean if there's a big demand for it if
we can do it fine but we have to be very
careful that we don't clutter our site
with so many different functions that
satisfy user a or b or c but are not
necessarily that useful
because it just makes the site more and
more complicated and if anything we have
too many functions there and we should
be reducing them people have trouble
understanding what we want them to do a
lot of people just like to be told do
this then do this then do this with
fewer
bells and whistles and options so
i'd have to be persuaded that that was a
really useful thing to do and i'm not
sure it is
what do you think of chunk learning a
language well there's been a lot of
you know
people write stuff and there's theories
about you know describing things that
are pretty well obvious
obviously we learn
we learn
phrases we learn chunks of the language
it's less like this term
collocations i mean we have to learn
which words go together with
which other words and therefore when i
read a language i regularly say phrases
these are chunks that i want to learn
and now with text to speech in most
languages you can actually hear the
phrase and it's all a part of learning
when you talk about
you know genders in romance languages if
you learn the phrase with the
you know the adjective in there it's
going to help you remember the gender
if you are doing chinese and you learn a
phrase and you hear the intonation it's
going to help you with
the intonation with the tones so
learning phrases chunks collocations
whatever you want to call it is
obviously a good thing to do
do you think it's bad to learn languages
because you want respect from others
whatever motivates you is good
uh i wish link had polytonic alphabet
support for greek that text to speech
doesn't work
i'd have to go back in and check it
seems to me that the the text to speech
did work but i i can't answer that right
now
um
you know greek is not one of our main
supported languages
i could look into it we do in in
japanese and in chinese and a bunch of
others we do have a phonetic sort of uh
transliteration there i'd have to i'll
look into it
i noticed that your cognitive science
says we need some downtime to let the
information get into long term and sleep
is important all right scott that's
interesting
uh with already known vocabulary that we
recognized during quick reading yeah
nikos i can't comment uh
right now it's not we have been asked
for that before uh mark who is in charge
of link said we're not going to do it i
can't give you all the details on why
but uh yeah i can't say much more right
now and i'm going to have to leave a
little early today so i'm going to rush
through these
is the immersive method worth it i don't
know what the immersive method is
but uh
to some extent link is immersive because
you are immersing yourself in content
i find it to that extent the mini
stories which jump you into an
intermediate level of content but with
enough listening and reading and
reviewing you can get a toehold on the
language and move along and if you have
any issues of grammar you can look up
the grammar you can look it up by
googling or we have our grammar
resources now in a number of languages
and again you'll find those in your
profile that's not a very obvious place
to put them but they are there
um
is it hard to find
is it hard to find good content in
chinese with pinyin what are your
recommendations i don't i'm not
other people might recommend i'm not
doing mandarin so i don't know but you
just google
yes uh mike gargano asks if i learned
cantonese yes i did
hello steve how do you approach
repetitive listening to striker balance
between novelty and repetition
so
uh
i find obviously i'd like to bring in
new more difficult content for example
in arabic but yes this struggle and i
can't really understand it so then i go
back to stuff that i've done before in
all of my many stories or in who is she
that we have in arabic
in the early lessons there are very few
words that are still yellow most are all
white i know but as i progress there's
you know less than 20 30 40 50 there's
10 15 20 30 words that i still haven't
learned
and even in the earlier lessons there's
structures that you know when i first
went through them i didn't realize the
significance that this might be a
certain form in arabic so i find when i
go on back go back and listen again and
again i'm noticing things every time
something i hadn't noticed the time
before and so i find that searching for
these things that are new or
rediscovering
things that i've you know i've
sort of learned in subsequent lessons
and i now see them in that earlier
lesson and i hadn't noticed it the first
time around i find all of that sort of
interesting but it is a conundrum and i
get back to this fact that we don't have
enough intermediate content so i'm
bouncing back and forth between content
that's too difficult for me
and stuff that i've now been over 10 15
20 times uh difficult question danielle
i can't give you a better answer than
that
steve i need to get study plan for
learning french english upper media
get on link listen and read you don't
need so much detailed planning make sure
you put in
listen an hour a day it's easy to get in
wherever on transportation or whatever
and then follow up by reading and
reviewing words
how do you understand without looking at
subtitles well improve your listening
ability
a silly question how to distinguish lies
and lives
when the speaker
i mean
to understand when the speaker speaks
quickly you have to improve your
listening ability and that takes a lot
of
listening
uh cafe you know what
unfortunately the arabic script that
comes across here is so small and my
reading ability is so poor i'm not going
to take up a lot of time to read through
it
but
i'm sorry
when i get better
you talk about attitude could you sum up
this attitude philosophy in a few sense
is it about enjoying the language and
the process so you stick to it every day
okay jeff
the attitude is
i like the language
i think i can learn the language
i kind of enjoy learning it but at any
rate it's it's something that i so much
want to achieve that i'm prepared to put
in the time
i believe that the method i'm using is
correct
i believe it's a worthwhile place for me
to be so while i'm learning the language
i'm not thinking about gee i wish i were
doing something else
it's that sort of positive i can do it i
want to do it i believe i can do it
that's the attitude and of course as i
mentioned in the previous
video curiosity i'm curious i want to
discover
this world the world that's behind that
language all of those things are driving
me
and in that regard if you have
interesting content compelling content
that's also going to drive you
um
okay mr steve do you think a person
living in another country so far
some other language no you cannot lose
your mind i mean there might be some
rare example but overwhelmingly i don't
think so and i don't forget those
languages that i've spoken a lot
any tips to get to lots of listening and
reading
what is the hardest language that you
know they're all hard in different ways
uh you know
chinese because of tones and characters
slavic languages because of their
complicated grammar arabic because of
the script and the grammar they're all
different
the issue is
how attractive is the language to you if
it's attractive enough you just blaze
through the difficulties
uh
i've been using tprs for mandarin i've
been studying for a year and i still
have problems recalling words even in
class i struggle
yeah a tprs i mean
i have not been in class learning
mandarin using tprs
to me the function is it's the same it's
a lot of listening and reading and the
brain will gradually get used to it uh
tprs i mean to me
being in a classroom environment with a
lot of non-native speakers would would
discourage my language learning i feel
that most of the language learning i
have to do it on my own so i would my
advice would be don't worry about what
happens in the classroom the classroom
is tension either you're annoyed that
someone can't answer questions or you're
concerned that you're not keeping up
with there's a whole bunch of tension in
the classroom that i'm not a big fan of
if you're learning on your own it's you
and the text you don't understand you
listen again you read again you're
constantly pushing yourself yourself
forward into the language by yourself
ah by the way i think your gene
okay
is there something i uh yeah green
whiskey uh can you can you laugh can you
become fluent a year
depends on the language
any tips to get the comprehension from
sometimes i understand when i look at
the subjects when i don't this whole
business of comprehension is linked
uh how did you learn
well mandarin in one year full time
every day six seven hours three hours a
day one on one paid for by the canadian
government
and then another three four hours of
listening and reading
how many times should i repeat the same
lesson of their week okay again
repeating the same lesson is not because
you listen the same lesson now over and
over and over again it's because you go
lesson one two three four five back to
lesson one two three four five six seven
back to lesson one
be guided by what by what you want to do
reading about seven financial steps for
it has more than one thousand pages in
front of others should i note the
unknown words or just keep going
i would just keep going you understand
the
you can figure out what the meaning is
you understand the context you're
interested in it
uh
what are the best language link is the
best language learning app
so getting back to this uh
yeah just keep going i find in any word
i look up although if a word keeps on
appearing and you simply don't know what
it means it starts to bug you look it up
but you may forget the meaning even
though you look it up
if there were alarms that you could
master just with the click of a finger
which would it be
i don't know
when you see video with a lot of words
in the subtitles what should you do
well then obviously
um
keep going
unifluency in three months you think
this is possible no
i said to a neuroscientist saying
petersburg who said to make activities
more difficult than is comfortable to
stimulate the mind i think that applies
the language too
there is a very
famous uh hungarian
chick check
which i i i
very complicated name but the gist of it
is you want to have as i understand it
to be in what's known as the sort of
state of flow
is when you have a challenge that's
difficult but you can actually cope with
it so if it's too difficult like my
arabic podcasts
it's tough if it's just a little
difficult then i feel a great sense of
achievement and the brain likes to feel
this sense of achievement
so i think that's the ideal place to be
how do you improve your listening
comprehension of native speakers in
mandarin when they speak very fast
everybody speaks their native language
very quickly uh it's just more of the
same i don't think there's any
uh
do you all these questions about how do
you react when people are not nice to
you i'm not gonna answer them because i
don't deal with those things it doesn't
bother me i just focus on learning the
language
uh if you happen to
ask on do you stay 10 minutes he will
answer there's 10 minutes to let what
earphones are using when exercising
airpods from from apple
uh
why do you can even pronounce storyline
like that i don't know i'm thinking we
should start with authentic material
languages then work backwards
i found that many stories have been a
very good sweet spot
don't you ever make any effort to
improve your writing skills in the
language you're learning no because i
don't need to write
but as writing is very good if i had to
write chinese i had to write in french
when i was at university there
uh
is the free version of leak helpful i
think so we have a lot of content there
that you can download from our libraries
you can only import five i find the
import function very useful and you
can't create a lot of links but
as a repository we have a tremendous
amount
of um
of audio and text material in a number
of languages it's it's unique and
definitely go there
yeah daniel i don't know anything about
tprs
resources
online for japanese but you can get good
get on our forum and link and ask other
people
uh
okay and with that i'm gonna cut it
short today as it was we went uh almost
48 minutes
so
there we go thank you everyone
and we look forward to the next one
thank you bye
you